welcome everybody to quick traps the
series where i showcase quick high
scoring openings traps so you can avoid
falling into them or trap other players
this week we're going over the max lang
attack this opening is great for
beginners and intermediate players the
lines are very tactical which will lead
to lots of wins and will help develop a
strong tactical sense the lines are also
very forcing so you won't have to
memorize a ton of lines and if black's
not prepared they can get in a lot of
trouble and lose very quickly let's get
started so the max lang attack comes out
of the scotch gambit so we start with e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 and d4 this is
the scotch game a very popular opening
from beginner all the way up to master
level this pawn should be taken as
whenever one side gets a pawn duo in the
center it's generally a good idea to try
to eliminate that if you can and here
black can so black plays e takes d4
bishop c4 white goes for the scotch
gambit knight to f6 and white plays the
double gambit with castles here black
has two main moves knight takes e4 is
the most popular move the double gambit
accepted but bishop c5 is what we're
going to be looking at today the max
lang attack a very dangerous opening for
both sides oftentimes in games that
reach this position the player who is
better prepared will emerge victorious
let's look at some lines white should
certainly start with e5 and where does
black move this night well black
actually can't move that night at all
moving the knight would be a huge
mistake so already we can see if black
doesn't know the theory here it's very
easy to go wrong if black tries knight
e4 we simply play rookie one we're
attacking this knight the knight's
trapped it can't go anywhere so you have
to defend it with the pawn and just an
example line could go something like
this d5 e takes d6 bishop f5 the knight
must be protected again d takes c7 queen
takes c7 black now has this isolated
pawn which will be a target later but
that's not the worst of black's problems
because this knight is still pinned to
their king knight bd2 protect again with
queen e7 we simply take that knight
takes c4 bishop takes c4 bishop g5 and
where is the queen going f6 knight d2
white will win a piece no matter what
you can feel free to take a look at
these lines after knight e4 in the
analysis yourself but all of them result
in good positions for white and the
moves are all very easy and natural to
find with white so it's not worth
exploring any additional lines here the
second move i can try in this position
is knight g4 here we continue with
bishop f4 we must defend our pawn and if
black continues with a very natural move
castle is the most popular move in the
position we simply play h3 the knight
has no squares it must retreat to h6 d5
or knight takes f2 loses material so
when the knight comes back to f6 we
simply capture this knight black's king
side is destroyed and they're going to
have a very hard time defending in this
middle game we continue with c3 to break
down black's center here this center
pawn is very annoying for us as white so
we're willing to be down a pawn in order
to get rid of that center pawn and get
fast development for our knight this
knight is going to come to f6 the queen
will come to d2 attacking h6 straight
away and white is of course going to be
better here white will have a very nice
game from this position all right so
what if black does know the correct move
after we play e5 they play d5 and this
line is very forcing we start by taking
this knight d takes c4 rookie one check
bishop e6 and knight g5 and white has a
very sneaky threat here because it looks
like they hang their f6 pawn but their
threat is knight takes e6 and after f
takes e6 we play queen h5 we fork the
king and the bishop and this is the most
common trap in the max lang attack and
you can trap even very high rated
players you can see here in the database
there's a 2500 that got trapped 2400
that got trapped so even very strong
players will fall for this trap you
cannot play any of these red highlighted
moves queen d7 queen takes f6 g takes f6
it's all the same we simply capture this
bishop and then we fork the king and the
bishop here if black continues with g6
we take the bishop first and now if
black castles queen side we might even
be able to pick up more material with
bishop g5 skewering the queen to the
rook now and black can actually escape
this skewer with queen to f8 however
queen to f8 is a very tricky move to see
as evidenced by the fact that it's the
third most commonly played move here
even though it's the best move in the
position so if black castles queen side
you have a very good chance to pick up
even more material queen f5 the most
common move queen takes f5 e takes f5
and white will be up a full rook for two
pawns this should be a pretty easy win
for white going back to this position i
just want to explore what happens if
black castles here now this is actually
worse than queen takes f6 or queen d7 or
g takes f6 because here we're going to
play f takes g7 the rook is attacked so
black has two moves they either take the
pawn or move their rook either way it's
bad news bears if king takes g7
rook takes e6 that rook is untouchable
because of the knight fork and if rook
to e8 is played we simply play queen h5
and it's lights out for black h7 sit f7
is hit there's no recovering from this
so that's a really nice trap with queen
takes f6 but what if black plays the
best move which is queen d5 stopping
white's threat of taking the knight and
forking the bishop here we're gonna hit
back with the next move knight c3 and
that knight is untouchable the queen is
not defended by the bishop the rook is
pinning that the queen must move again
the queen moves to f5 here white should
continue with knight c to e4 black will
safeguard their king and now only now do
we play g4 it's very important to play
knight c e4 before you play g4 if you
play g4 first white can get in a lot of
trouble for example if you play g4 here
on move 11 g4 queen g6 now if you try
knight ce4 they're simply bishop b6
white's king will never be safe and
black has no problems here but after g4
the queen must move again queen also
must stay tied to the bishop so she's
really only got two spots e5 or d5 now
if you've never seen the position before
you might think that e5 is a little suss
because you're lined up with this rook
here but in fact queen to e5 is the best
move and queen to d5 loses the game
straight away after f takes g7 rook hg8
knight f6 it's a fork queen back to d6
knight ge4 now hitting the queen again
queen e7 knight takes g8 rook takes g8
and bishop g5 the queen cannot stay tied
to this bishop f6 is a good try so that
after bishop takes f6 now you say hey
you can't take my bishop because your
bishop will hang well after queen f7
knight takes c5 black realizes that
their bishop is also hanging queen takes
f6 knight takes e6 white is up a full
rook and will be able to safeguard their
king white wins this one so queen d5 is
not playable here black has to play
queen e5 so after the queen moves to e5
we're gonna hit the queen again with
knight to f3 queen d5 we're going to
take this pawn on g7 now hitting the
rook rook hg8 knight f6 getting the fork
on the queen in the rook and after queen
d6 we actually don't take the rook you
might ask yourself in this position why
not just take the rook and be up the
exchange well black's attack is
unfortunately just too strong if you
play knight takes g8 here white's
trading one of their best pieces and
black just gets the free reload with
rook takes g8 white's king safety center
and development are all super bad
white's king is never going to be safe
for the rest of the game they don't have
enough compensation for the exchange and
black is going to be better so white
actually can't take the exchange here
they have to come back knight to e4 and
there's one last trap where if black
plays queen to e7 they fall into the
skewer
something similar we saw earlier with
bishop g5 but the best move for black
here is queen d5 and at this point black
has avoided all of the traps they've
avoided the traps on move six on move
nine on move 12 and 16 and everywhere in
between they've passed the test and the
best white has here is actually a draw
by threefold repetition knight to f6
queen d6 94 queen d5 and it's a draw by
threefold repetition that being said
don't let that scare you away from
playing this opening you will rarely
ever get this draw by three-fold
repetition i've only gotten it a couple
times in over five years of playing this
opening so it very rarely happens much
much much more frequently you will get
your opponent in a trap or you will
deviate sometime before this so don't
worry about it it's still a very strong
opening and that's it that's all you
need to know about the max lang attack
if you study these lines and commit them
to memory you will have a great time
crushing black in this opening remember
to like the video if you enjoyed it
thank you very much for watching take
care i'll see you next time